for jude kilby the public inquiry being
held into the pandemic in scotland will
be in memory of her father
harry carriage caught covid in a care
home in april last year and died 18 days
later i didn't get there in time
and i didn't even go in because
the home had lots of covert in it i
wasn't going to go in there when my dad
was already dead
um
so it was it was incredibly distressing
and we don't want other people to go
through
this
so if you are 16 or older
the scottish arm of the campaign group
covid 19 bereaved families for justice
pushed for this inquiry and got the
result they wanted the inquiry will look
at all matters related to the handling
of the pandemic that are within our
devolved competence and this will
include of course the situation in our
care homes however we will also lays
closely with the uk government and other
devolved governments on the
likely terms of a uk wide inquiry
failures in care homes will be one
crucial line of inquiry alongside the
wider health impacts of kovid the effect
on education and society and the
economic impacts in scotland have a
pandemic that is far from over
in political terms scotland's government
has stolen a march on westminster
boris johnson has promised a uk wide
inquiry next year
campaigners are hoping this announcement
in scotland will speed up that process
the group says it doubts westminster's
commitment
we've asked seven times can we have a
meeting with the prime minister and his
then health secretary and seven times
we're told no
there is no intention to meet with the
families that i know of
uh he is so far behind where scotland
now is
and i hope it puts pressure on him to
act sooner on behalf of of all the
bereaved
family members throughout the uk
there's now increasing pressure on wales
and northern ireland to hold their own
inquiries that scotland's was announced
as the daily number of covid cases hit a
new record here will be lost on no one
gerard's sky news glasgow